(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre as formas
de pagamento dos leilões ex-prejudiciais.
Os leilões ex-prejudiciais, eles são mais flexíveis
quanto a forma de pagamento em relação aos
leilões judiciais.
Isso porque os leilões judiciais realizados pela justiça
estadual, eles têm uma restrição de como pode
ser parcelado aquele bem.
A lei fala que no mínimo vai existir
uma entrada de 25% sobre o valor
da arrematação e o valor da arrematação pode
ser parcelado em até 30 vezes.
No módulo 3 a gente vai ter uma
aula específica sobre as formas de pagamento dos
leilões judiciais.
Agora a gente vai ficar somente com a
forma de pagamento dos leilões ex-prejudiciais.
Nessa modalidade de leilão, ou seja, o leilão
ex-prejudicial, o pagamento é mais flexível porque
cada credor que está levando o imóvel a
leilão vai poder definir como vai ser o
pagamento daquele leilão.
Então a gente vai passar desde leilões onde
só permitem pagamento à vista até leilões onde
permitem o pagamento parcelado ou financiado e nesse
caso pode ser que exista algum benefício como
algum desconto para pagamento à vista.
Existem alguns casos então de leilão ex-prejudicial
onde o credor financiário permite o financiamento daquele
imóvel em até 420 vezes.
Não há uma regra limitada como existem nos
leilões judiciais.
Então no leilão ex-prejudicial cada credor vai
definir como vai ser feito o se vai
ser feito à vista, se vai ser possível
parcelar, se vai ser possível financiar, se existindo
o parcelamento ou financiamento vai existir algum benefício
no pagamento à vista como percentual de desconto.
Os juros que vai incidir no parcelamento ou
financiamento vai ser indicado pelo credor financiário no
edital do leilão.
Esses juros são compatíveis com os juros de
uma aquisição normal, de uma aquisição normal de
um imóvel financiado através de um banco.
A taxa de juros vai ser muito semelhante,
não vai ter grande distinção.
Sobre o prazo de pagamento do leilão ex
-prejudicial, a lei também não define um prazo
específico para pagamento do leilão ex-prejudicial.
Então cabe a cada edital de cada imóvel
estipular qual vai ser o prazo de pagamento
daquele valor.
Existem editales que colocam que o pagamento deve
ser feito em 24 horas, 48 horas, 72
horas ou até cinco dias.
Cabe ao interessado em arrematar aquele imóvel verificar
qual é o prazo de pagamento daquele imóvel
especificamente.
Uma observação importante caso você queira recorrer ao
parcelamento ou financiamento de um imóvel.
Você deve, antes de participar desse leilão, saber
qual é a margem que você tem disponível
para financiar um imóvel.
Isso porque um banco vai fazer um levantamento
de sua vida para saber se você é
uma boa pessoa ou não para contar com
o financiamento de um imóvel, que um imóvel
geralmente tem um valor mais elevado.
Você vai ter que ter crédito para isso,
vai ter que ter bons antecedentes quanto aos
seus pagamentos, vai ter que ter nome limpo.
Então é necessário que você faça esse levantamento
antes de participar de um leilão exatamente para
que você não faça uma proposta que depois
não vai ser aceita.
O objetivo de quem participa de um leilão
é arrematar o imóvel, então não faz sentido
você fazer uma proposta sem você saber qual
é o crédito que você tem disponível para
financiar ou para parcelar aquele imóvel.
Então você deve comparecer antes a uma agência
de um banco para saber qual é o
seu crédito.
Em alguns editais de leilão vai ficar estipulado
que você só pode financiar com aquele credor
que está especificamente fazendo aquele leilão.
Então, por exemplo, pode ser que o edital
de um leilão de um imóvel feito pelo
Bradesco coloque uma previsão que o financiamento só
poderá ser feito com Bradesco, não poderá ser
feito o financiamento com outro banco.
Depois poderia existir algum caso de portabilidade desse
financiamento, mas nem sempre esses casos de portabilidade
são interessantes porque existe uma taxa para fazer
essa portabilidade.
Então primeiro faça a leitura do edital, veja
se é possível ou não fazer aquele financiamento
com outro banco, se você deve ficar vinculado
àquele banco que está levando o imóvel a
leilão e compareça a uma agência para saber
qual é o seu limite de crédito para
que você possa fazer uma proposta que seja
aceita e não depois seja recusada pelo banco.
Quando existe alguma proposta de pagamento parcelado ou
financiado, o leiloeiro vai levar essa proposta, a
proposta mais interessante, ao credor fiduciário que está
realizando aquele leilão, na sua grande maioria os
bancos, e esse credor deve aceitar ou não
aquela proposta.
Caso ele aceite, você vai ser notificado que
o credor aceitou e vai seguir com o
trâmite normal para o pagamento e depois financiamento
daquele valor.
A comissão do leiloeiro nunca entra no parcelamento
ou no financiamento, a comissão do leiloeiro vai
ser sempre paga à vista, usualmente a comissão
do leiloeiro representa 5% do valor da
arrematação, pode ser que em algum caso específico,
a comissão do leiloeiro seja reduzida, isso geralmente
acontece em leilão judicial, em leilão excrujudicial é
difícil isso acontecer, mas fique atento ao que
fale o edital também para saber qual vai
ser a comissão do leiloeiro e saiba que
você deve pagar a comissão do leiloeiro à
vista.
Financiamento de um leilão excrujudicial é uma grande
oportunidade para quem não tem todo o capital
para entrar num leilão ou para quem tem
o capital mas não quer usar aquele capital
de uma vez só, ou quer usar o
capital que tem às vezes para diversificar em
um ou mais imóveis ou até em outros
tipos de investimento.
O mais comum é que os bancos aceitem
fazer um financiamento de até 80% do
valor de imóvel, mas existem casos em que
as pessoas têm margem maiores em que é
possível que o banco concorde que 95%
do valor daquele imóvel seja financiado, nesse caso
especificamente a pessoa vai pagar somente 5%
daquele imóvel à vista e a comissão do
leiloeiro que geralmente é 5% também à
vista, o resto vai ser todo financiado.
Uma condição muito interessante que é possível no
leilão excrujudicial é o uso do FGTS para
comprar um imóvel em leilão.
É mais comum que leilões realizados pela caixa
econômica permitam a utilização do FGTS para pagar
o produto da arrematação, mas nada impede que
algum outro banco, algum outro credor fiduciário permita
que o pagamento daquele leilão especificamente vai ser
feito com o FGTS.
O FGTS ele tem uma série de regras
para que ele possa ser usado, como por
exemplo, você não pode comprar com o FGTS
um imóvel que foi comprado em até três
anos antes sendo utilizado o FGTS, você tem
que utilizar seu FGTS para comprar um imóvel
na cidade onde você trabalha ou em cidades
limítrofes, você não pode usar o FGTS se
você já tiver um imóvel, uma série de
regrinhas assim, para a gente não se estender
muito aqui nessa aula, eu vou deixar o
link da cartilha do FGTS aqui na descrição
da aula e esse cartilha do FGTS foi
elaborado pela própria Caixa Econômica Federal, então lá
você pode tirar todas as dúvidas se você
pode ou não comprar um imóvel em leilão
usando o seu FGTS, tenha sempre em mente
que você só pode fazer essa opção se
o edital do leilão permitir que você faça
a arrematação usando o FGTS, então localizando no
edital que é possível comprar aquele imóvel especificamente
com o FGTS e você se enquadrando nas
hipóteses legais de utilização do FGTS, todas as
hipóteses legais estão nessa cartilha de utilização do
FGTS, você poderá tranquilamente utilizar seu FGTS para
comprar aquele imóvel que o edital permita, não
necessariamente você pode pagar só a entrada, às
vezes se você tiver uma margem boa de
FGTS, você pode pagar a integralidade do valor
da arrematação usando o seu FGTS, então se
você tiver interesse em arrematar o imóvel em
leilão utilizando esse valor de FGTS que você
tem retido, dê uma olhada na cartilha, veja
se você se enquadra em todos os requisitos
e permitindo o edital ou a utilização do
FGTS, faça o uso tranquilamente.
Outra possibilidade que os leilões exclujudiciais oferecem para
o pagamento do valor da arrematação é o
uso da carta de consórcio e aí cabe
a mesma regra do que a gente acabou
de falar do FGTS, existem editais que vão
permitir a utilização da carta de consórcio contemplada
e outros editais que não vão permitir a
utilização da carta de consórcio contemplada.
Caso você queira fazer a utilização de uma
carta de consórcio contemplada que você possua para
a arrematação de um bem imóvel em leilão,
verifique o que o edital específico daquele bem
está falando, se vai ser ou não possível
utilizar essa carta de consórcio.
Então essas são as formas de pagamento para
que você adquira um imóvel em leilão exclujudicial,
vale sempre o que está escrito em edital,
se o edital permitir a utilização da FGTS,
se o edital vai permitir a utilização de
carta de consórcio, se o edital vai permitir
somente pagamento à vista ou se vai ser
possível naquele imóvel específico parcelar ou financiar.
Caso você queira recorrer ao financiamento, saiba que
você precisa ter crédito para isso, só vai
poder recorrer ao financiamento aquele que é considerado
um bom pagador, ou seja, que tem um
nome limpo na praça, que tem uma margem
de crédito boa, isso vai depender do salário
que cada um de vocês possua, não tem
como a gente falar se vai ou não
ser concedido um financiamento.
Para você não correr o risco de fazer
uma proposta de financiamento e depois essa proposta
ser recusada pelo credor fiduciário, recorra antes a
uma análise de crédito que você possui para
que você possa fazer uma proposta de financiamento
sabendo que essa proposta tem condições de ser
aceita.
O objetivo de todo mundo que arremata um
imóvel em leilão é ficar com o imóvel
e não fazer uma proposta e depois essa
proposta não ser aceita pelo credor fiduciário.
Só queria deixar aqui para vocês no final
dessa aula uma observação, a gente vai estudar
um pouco mais à frente no módulo 3
sobre os leilões judiciais, que no caso do
leilão judicial existe a possibilidade de parcelamento, mas
que a lei diz que caso ocorra um
lance à vista, esse lance ele tem preferência
sobre o lance parcelado, ainda que o lance
parcelado fosse mais vantajoso.
Como é que funciona um leilão excrediticial?
Em regra, um leilão excrediticial, quando o edital
coloca a possibilidade de financiamento, a pessoa vai
poder financiar o valor ali de qualquer lance
que ela dê.
Então se o seu lance for o último,
você for o vencedor daquele leilão e você
quiser utilizar a possibilidade de financiamento, via de
regra você vai poder usar nesse seu lance.
Não tem essa regrinha do leilão judicial, que
o lance à vista prefere sobre o lance
parcelado, mas fique atento a essa possibilidade e
confirme no edital especificamente que você queira participar.
Entre em contato com o leiloeiro, leia atentamente
o edital e verifique se realmente você vai
poder financiar qualquer lance que for oferecido, isso
obviamente de acordo com a sua margem de
financiamento, sobre a análise que o banco vai
fazer sobre o seu crédito e é importante
você já ter essa noção previamente, para que
você faça um lance, que você saiba que
realmente existe a possibilidade de você financiar.